Joe Biden has just announced a plan to
spend
5.7 million dollars on psychological
support for Liberal journalists who are
trolled online the bide Administration
has approved almost 6 million bucks to
George Washington University to create a
program that will provide psychological
care to journals who believe their
targets of misinformation-driven
harassment campaigns which is just a
slogan to be used to make liberal
journalists seem like victims my only
take on this is In fairness to Biden I
do agree that liberal journalists could
use a lot of psychiatric care they could
stand to benefit from that
six million dollars is not going to go
nearly far enough that will be a drop in
the bucket to the kind of psychological
correction that liberal journalists need
and this reminds you that the supposed
fourth estate the brave independent
journalists speaking truth to power are
nothing but